So, did you ever end up hooking up with Jean?
Oh yeah, you know it, bub.
She is a fiery one.
Oh, good for you.
Good for you.
Good for me.
I've always liked the idea of you two together.
How's your Aunt May doing?
She is good.
She just got a new sewing kit and it's awesome.
I heard that Bruce Banner is having some marital issues with Betty, which is too bad.
And I don't really know how to...
How's it going, troops?
Hey, Cap!
Not another boy scout.
Hey Steve, how's it going?
I feel pretty good, how about you, Peter?
It's going good, glad to have you here.
How's school going?
It's wonderful.
Oh god, kill me now!
For my own curiosity, both of you have fought in the war.
Which wars have you guys fought in before?
Civil.
The greatest war ever: World War II.
That's cute.